hey Andrew are you ready ready or not I am no
I wanted you to respond and then I was going to
say or not or not and then and it didn't go that
way I also was also thinking about doing ready
or not here I come you can't hide maybe this
is about hiding maybe it's not we don't know
because we've never seen this movie before and
we're about to watch it for the first time and
you guys are watching it with us so leave a like
comment subscribe all that good stuff hit the
notification do you know anything about this I've
never even heard of this movie is that true Craig
asked me have you ever seen rer and I'm like I
haven't even heard of this movie I don't even
know what we're in for but I'm excited what you're
not a samaro weaving stand that's the only thing
I know I just know she's in Scream Six that's it
oh and that's where the directors come from also
the OC fans Adam Brody was on the cover and I saw
that picture I'm not ashamed to admit I do like
that show except for season 4 was not great but
why would you be ashamed to admit that it's one
of the best shows of all time California here we
come ready or not if you guys want to watch the
full length Reaction watch along where you syn
up with your own copy uh that's for the super
sexy rejects go to our patreon that's where you
could do that Greg and John cover several shows
over there exclusively with reaction highlights
and watch alongs included that's only for the
sexiest of people the people that are the most
ready or not I say it so sarcastically no you
got it in that was perfect well I always get
it in and we're gonna get this in right woof
now great first image okay going
to say that's a creepy way to
start Le's Gambit take a risk gain the
advantage was that good and Sinister I'm not
going to lie that got my heart heart racing
a little bit although State of Affairs of
everything my heart's already just racing
in general but yes you got me there
already this would be a good house to
have a haunted house though maybe that's
what it is we actually don't know come
on hurry stayed on the same tracking shot
so far get in and don't come out Daniel I'm
scared Daniel please they're trying to kill me
please oh my goodness he's in here God no oh my
gosh okay Daniel just threw him under
the bus out of him Daniel I'm so proud
of you pleas well he had the guy who got
shot had a wedding ring on the woman was
crying for him so I'm assuming that's
his wife that was Elaine he shouted
out for her is this like a welcome to
the family type of thing don't think
so now we're about to see Daniel right for better
worse okay saman with them big eyes poor sickness
and in he help till death to his part your
family is richer than God intimidates the hell
out of me your dad definitely hat you and your
alcohol brother keeps hitting on me I want her
to actually say that at the wedding alcoholic
brother keeps hitting on me I feel like that's
relevant I honestly can't wait to be a part of
your moderately [__] up him moderately hi hey
don't see the bribe before it's bad luck they are
the family of the man that I love and I want them
to accept me without you I'm one of us hey Daniel
I've been sent to fetch you hey the drunk brother
Han bro it's not too late to flee you know you
don't belong in this family I mean mean that as a
compliment foreshadowing we could just leave
thanks for the presence go yourselves no I'm
serious I'm serious I I'm giving you an out oh
no I would listen to this but then we don't have
a movie if anybody ever gave me an out right
before we got married like that I think I'd
take it like why what what's happening but it's
an out together though it's not an out like away
from me are you ready for this oh no good good
uh drop wow that is a very nice house I live
there almost reminds me of Billy Madison so much
better oh there's krid from Mission Impossible
and scream I think of him from Revenge smile
and smile please the more natural don't take
it personally they're just trying to figure out
if you're a gold digg you know like my wife to
the the left she's pretty enough the last call
the Dive Bar kind of way oh Andy McDow where
the hell's your sister I'm shorts fitcher's
fault he's useless but he's one of us there
good composer hi hi hey Andy mcdell we've been
waiting for you your blood isn't blue enough
they said the same thing about me stand tall
and that was good advice stand tall and F them
this duo with the screams and VHS Matt and Tyler
I have to tell shut up take your pencil I tell you
something grace honey taking them off wrecked
into the point I like it police sit here what
Jesus anene can you give us a minute everyone is
waiting yeah I'll be down in a few minutes what
the hell was that that's that's why aene she has
um well she is boundary issues yeah you think of
course you have a secret door servants Corridor
they run all through the house he has to tell
her who's waiting oh goodness I I trying to tell
you um how is he going to say this so at midnight
you have to play a game it's just something
we do when someone new joins the family shall
we play a game you draw a card could be back
gaming croquet Checkers for all I know I know
is his name Ben I know it's stupid it's a little
weird is he the little boy he's the little one
that was hidden in at the beginning you just
have to play and then you you are officially
part of the family honestly it means more to
them than the wedding itself you are leaving
out a lot of details why not tell her this before
should have told her this on the first date if we
get married um you might have to play a game of
life in death I'm sure Mr leale is with us today
so how much have you told her nothing if she
pulls that card are you prepared to do what's
necessary loving this intro yeah sick setup
tension High way to drag it out I'm sure
there's animosity in some family members
who's spouse like well yeah didn't survive
versus members who did survive it's like oh so
much animosity one of our children has brought
him a good one and you don't know how grateful we
are that you brought Alex back to us try to bring
him back into the fold we're his family she's
obviously going to pull the card damn hi Fitch
Bradley I'm Emily oh your dress is amazing
I totally stoping you on Instagram oh really
that's I'm so excited to be a part of your family
he will decide that you continue to exist I would
love to be part of the woman's family she's so
welcoming this is how I picture Army Hammer's
family right so this room is reserved for
family members only even if you survive is
this some a family you want to be part of or
is it you have no choice even if you survive
kind of thing I don't know but if you pull the
card they hunt you and try to kill you I would
assume that's but if you make it out alive then
what it's like you have no choice type of thing
cuz now you're part of the club I'm wondering
or if they make you do something that you can't
leave great-grandfather enjoyed his games oh God
her innocence is about to be thrown out and she
has no family oh imagine if the person you're with
doesn't want to get married to you and you're like
why this is why he pushing it off I if I was part
of this family I would never get married probably
Victor set up a modest Printing Shop during the
Civil War manufacturing playing cards expanded
into sporting goods and board games plas family
games acquired four professional sports teams I
may call it luck but it's almost as if someone's
watching over us I love shots like this among Mr
leal's possessions was that box Mr leale proposed
a wager if great grandfather could solve the
mystery of the Box Mr leale would Finance any
Endeavor of grandfather's choosing we place a
blank playing card into the box drawing the card
and Mr leale will tell us which game to play I
got chess I got Old Maid I've never heard of
that really car game yeah my dear it is your
turn oh my God what a wild thing this
is what a premise [Laughter] yeah what does
it say girl it says you're creepy and scary
it says hide and seek or you really going to
play that oh goodness you get to be the one to
uh to hide yeah just come meet me in my room
okay I not want for real so weird let's turn
the Bell oh my gosh you're going to need to be
drunk for this you can hide anywhere inside the
house we then count 200 and try to um find
you no we never use the cameras we always
play the games as they wouldn't played in
great-grandfather's time what's the time
frame 100 seconds no no I mean for the the whole
game by morning you stay hidden Till Dawn there
you go Grace good luck you guys have a messed
up family he said to meet her in his room cuz
he wants to protector I would assume that's
it is he able to who wants to play a game
I would put some better attire on though but
she doesn't she doesn't understand she's in
a survival mode right now so this is the greatest
premise for a movie I've seen in I'm not going to
lie it's very inventive I will definitely give
it that it's very suspense obsessed with this
right now it's very it's very suspenseful Sam is
so good and she's selling every deey moment but
also too they're they're doing these other actors
are doing such a good job coming AC so creepy you
can tell how conflicted uh those two are like
they don't want to be part of this obviously
the husbands I mean but even Adam Brody she
on the other hand she enjoys this she just a
psychopath Tick Tock are or not Tick Tock are
you ready or not I should have played the song
you said earlier ready or not on the flip
side is she allow ow to self-defend herself
I think [Music] so that is such an easy place
to find in my opinion I don't know how she can
lock it how was your wedding night gra it was
just great just great I uh I sat an ad dader I
don't know is it an elevator does it move you
it can it can go up and down it's just not not
like you're obviously your all right go save your
woman go get Grace she is Grace she's dignity she
Grace Alex honey do you want some company is
this Adam Brody's wife I think so I'm pretty
sure it's ad Bron's wife but like did yall think
he was just going to stay put and sit there they
did [__] Georgie oh I have a
feeling though this time when one
of the kids sees her he's not going to
tell on her like in earlier in the film
Jesus jump scare good job let's go what are
we doing get down grab your CH
grab your okay that got me so
much George whoa my God guys I found her
jeez oh my God and now she knows does she look
like she's wearing a giant white wedding dress
why did you shoot her in the face sweetheart
you're supposed to name her she needs to be
alive for the ritual I think she understands
the game she's playing now she dies does this
count of course it does not count it
must be the bride hey it's going to be
okay move her we don't want Grace to see give
call it P yes it is you get the links oh my God
okay sweetie you got to get we got to get you
out of here right now okay stand up here we go
yeah I would be in a catatonic State too right
now okay girl no more you're a winner you got
that that was the dumbest movie of the entire
moment the movie people but she's a winner
she has to do it just not how you do that was
funny though if they don't kill you something
very bad will happen to the family you knew
what would happen if I pulled that car I I
I didn't think they'd actually go through
with it no no one ever pulls out it never
happens God stop talking so loud when you marry
into this family you have to play a game and if
you don't you die I know that sounds crazy but
you have to believe me it happened to my great
uncle is wife too same thing happened to my cousin
Rachel same thing happened to a bunch of people
that I never even met before I hope I marry into a
family like this it's a weird Supernatural mixture
that they just did interesting you you brought me
here you didn't warn me you wanted to get married
yeah it's all your fault straight down this H
way until you get to the service kitchen I'm
going to go down to the security room I'm going
to unlock all the doors I'm going to unlock all
the doors and then [__] run I have to I
would not be able to conjure up a a thought
go go you do love him yeah I know I feel you
there but she he's his only chance talk about
toxic bro I get it though I've fallen in
love with some [__] too girl we deserve
better I feel like he needed to give her a
weapon she needs a weapon get your game face
on baby I think though too like he wants some
kind of alternative where nobody gets her but
I feel just for self self-defense purposes
but yeah yeah rip that [__] yeah I don't
cares about the wedding dress right now what
do you think happens if they don't kill her
do you think every other member of the family
dies if if they don't kill her by Dawn I just
think just she's just part of the family she
won the game they said something bad happens
they believe if they don't kill her something
bad will happen I guess we're going to find
out cuz I have a s slight suspicion she's
going to survive but we shall see she could
be anywhere I think she is going to take
out at least one or two of them yeah found
her Jesus people this is why you don't do drugs
and shoot I don't know what I'm [Laughter]
doing there's so much tension
suspense I just can't even get a drink
yeah he doesn't want to play like this
I have to call the others no you don't
no this doesn't end well for you I just
don't want to be the one to serve you
up I'm begging you Redemption Daniel
you already did this at the beginning
this is why he's a drunk it's true what
they say the rich really are different
I'll give you a 10-second Head Start take
it I mean that was somewhat generous oh my God
what's wrong with you Alex may have been wrong
to keep Grace in the dark but do you remember
how you reacted when I told you about this you
didn't l o you couldn't wait to sign your soul
away where I came from and what my life was like
before I'd rather be dead from your lips they did
a bait and switch here they painted her like the
[__] or the him like the [__] now she knows
what's going on oh but Emily shot Claire in the
face so she's dead that's just a side note I love
Adam Brody I forgot my gun oh I hope she got it
it's okay you don't suck sweetheart here H why
don't you just use mine oh I would not entrust
her with any weapons right now I just saw like
that knew it knew it why does this always happen
me she's such a screw up so self-centered why
does this always happened to me come on let's
um go take a walk find your in edible even you
out a little bit even you out a little bit we
must oh she groaning that air
oh oh my God this is a really dark horror
film sound design is incredible oh my God
we should use the security cameras maybe
it was her husband that died oh the one
with the axe you have no respect for tradition
she's right don't you think great-grandfather
would have used the security cameras if
he had them it is such a cheat to turn on
the cameras cuz I make the rules of this
game yeah rules are rules you guys can't
cheat is she going to become a badass
by the end of this I mean she as I
say I'm losing some family members
tonight oh my God that gun is so old
school it's a cool look costume design strong
on this I would say take out yeah it is I would
say take out your cokehead sister-in-law
last she's not in a position to fire at
you this is going to make a lot of noise if she's
able to fire it oh God she doesn't want to have
to kill him he's not part of the family right
but he knows the nonsense that goes on there
but yeah I agreed I know but she knows you
know they call him the help she's a effing
foster kid that's why she has that strength
okay oh no his family member is going to walk
in scared at hide and
seek I'm like freaked out kind of need
you to hold my hand ah he's got a knife
I think he grabbed one too I don't know
if he's allowed to kill her yeah he's not
part of the game right yeah but he
could surf her up to them oh that's
true Let Her Go Let Her
Go this is like a master class in
suspense and tension yep let her
go move I'm afraid I can't do that oh no
don't show him how did you really think
I would be stupid enough yeah [__] yeah
I agree o I do love that line that he was
in support of his wife that was great
open the door he is get the that's my
wife he can't kill his dad yeah even if
he is a psychopath I guess still is your
father you got to help me she's everything
to me we'll get her out okaye he knew it I
knew it there's still that little kid
Georgie running around right I believe
so God she's the help she's over here she's
over here oh my God she's going to die right
now snitches get stitches [__] seriously
o Oh I thought his eye didn't something happen
to his eye she yeah she put the boiling water you
okay yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I thought from the
shot it looked like he was completely Fun by yeah
you should never have let him leave us excuse me
I knew the girl would draw that card and that he
would face the same choice I face you were right
you called that that's why she's so bitter he's
simply afraid of who he truly is like I was
you'll never know how it felt that night to
be told that the only man that I'd ever loved had
to die I should have killed Charles myself why he
is meant to lead he's the good son do you remember
and why is he the only one of us who has ever seen
Mr laale in his chair H interesting that's good
character depth with her character too to make
understand why she's so bitter too I wonder if
she's going to try to convince him to kill her
like family is everything was he awake for that
I think yeah this guy's useless is he watching
YouTube videos how to sober your wife from Coke
I love knives out but truthfully this is kind
of like a better Knives Out is is that the Ryan
Johnson yeah it's great but all stuck in the house
[__] oh did she just throw her the thing not I
think she dropped she jumped oh she did actually
jump oh wow I thought she just threw the Gown I
didn't think she actually threw herself out but
she knows if she leaves him yeah that's a good
point maybe he might die or they might kill him
that's a good point but she's going for it
anyway because F this I wouldn't blame her
this is information you should have told her yeah
but I don't think she can do it I think she turns
back yeah she definitely will she's going to ammo
up she going to get on a horse somebody's in here
for sure who do you think it is grounds keeper
uh it's the guy who's just texting or it could be
Georgie the little kid I don't know hav't seen him
oh no if it's a little kid what is she going to
do yeah good call finally I got one
prediction listen I know this is really
really stupid oh my dear Lord he shoots
her through the hand bro oh my dear Lord
yeah yeah seriously punch that kid um you're
you're going to need like some serious medical
attention right you got to hole through your
hand she fell in the trash shoot it's probably
Neosporin won't even help the infection in that
then oh these are all the bodies or what is it
what down there you had bodies I can't even
imagine the amount of pain she's in oh god
oh was that from the beginning the guy was oh
[Music] boy but Georgie's still up there too
yeah but does she have his gun I hope she took
his gun in this scenario if you had to shoot
the kid would you I mean incriminate yourself
we knew her white dress had to get bloody at
some point yeah right and she's uh ready for that
Beetle Juice wedding with the red dress this is
a sick Halloween costume with the converse
and the wedding dress yeah perfect attire
oh she's only got one hand oh what a shot what a
shot did you know did you know did
you know that was going to happen no
I did not I did not know that I did
not should have thought it oh it's
right through the hands oh god well
at least there's already a hole there
yeah I'm not trying to be [__] but can
you quiet down I or they're going to find
you I feel you but I don't blame
her for shouting I can't imagine
the amount of pain that is this is like
the greatest movie ever it's pretty damn
good this is why people love Samar she said oh
Georgie thank God he effing shot her take his gun
though get his gun who just throw Georgie down
there the cigarettes is like a whole theme of
this oh no she sees her and she would rather
die than go back to being [Music] [Applause]
poor oh oh no it's not even close to Dawn too
this [__] is dark don't you get through oh no
oh God who do you think it [Music] [Applause] is
thank who is it who is it they said get the out
of the way she's out divy up the wedding gifts
I love how pessimistic he is this is a game it
is a game go wait for Stevens he might need your
help not you two I want you out of the way try
not to kill anyone else she have an accent the
whole time Andy McDow I think she's she always
has an accent just in general just how she talks
it was just stronger than it had been oh her poor
back and her hand me yeah I know but the the hand
happened to her her back she did to herself to try
to get out yeah if you heard somebody screaming
in the road like that would you stop I'm sorry if
somebody was screaming in the road like that would
you have stopped I mean yeah if they're screaming
in the road like that you think they might kill
you I mean yeah be definitely be apprehensive but
Daniel help I'd be on guard for sure but I think
Daniel's going to save the day are you talking
about Adam Brody yeah he's saying Daniel help
Daniel's the one who initially got that person
kill he's going to get his Redemption from the
beginning I kind of think so we all deserve to
die my kids don't mommy hey what are you doing out
here it's a nice black eye you got immediately I
shot her with that gun I found why would you do
that that's what everyone else was trying to do
I'm so proud of you jeez IND doation much she
just said my kids don't deserve to die it's a
learned behavior I guess well I mean yeah and we
saw Adam Brody at the beginning to he say he's
right here yeah he needs a Redemption Arc not that
you can redeem what you've done he going to do hit
her uh I think that's exactly what he's going to
do yeah grab a rock or something yeah she's she's
got to be in such a low energy right now why he
like this maybe try to have a conversation with
him oh she's pushing on the skin thing yeah where
she burned him yeah it's so sad that
they have him doing their [Applause]
bidding and she's tough to do that with with her
hand too every single foster care kid that I know
is a beast just like so strong what's upbring I
mean you had a tough life already so yeah she's
a gangster I love this character somebody in
the back seat I feel like the Elaine with the
axe might be in the back seat I don't know we
haven't seen her in a while I feel like but she
leaves him alive and she doesn't run him over oh
I think she heard you that she was a beast no no
no that she was going to run him I thought she was
going to run him this is Justin your call may be
monitored for people trying to kill me can you
please help me that the car was reported stolen
I'm sorry but I have to shut it down please
Justin you shouldn't have made the call thanks
for using trip safe have a great night I hear how
wholeheartedly oh no do not put your head down do
not put your head down honey lift your head high
look around everything's going to be that's why
you should have ran him over listen to Roxy next
time oh oh no cuz they need her alive remember
right right they did say that yes Justin was the
least helpful person that's ever existed on the
planet out of people screw Justin we'll be there
shortly tell him I know you don't want to but wow
this man loves his classical music kill him kick
him and kill him I'm surprised she didn't run him
over because she's joh trying to kill somebody
yeah no I know but don't don't leave loose she
punched the boy in the face oh she has a look of
grit and determination oh the music's so loud he's
not going to hear them she should reach over and
choke them yeah turn on the music idiot [Music]
whoa that's an awesome shot awesome shot I
think the music in this is amazing
way to enhance every single scene
yeah I'm sure right now like as much as it sucked
being a foster kid she's very grateful right now
and also like Vu oh no you don't want to kill me
you don't want me to die no I don't didn't she say
he was flirting with her at the yeah drunkenly I
am not who you think I am Alex is the one who got
out if anyone was going to save you it would have
been him oh maybe he kills his brother I was so
far off in every prediction just now and she made
me feel like I could be good too so if it comes
down to you or her I choose her except you still
put her in this position I don't think that you
believe that a girl that you've known for a year
and a half knows you better than I do is there any
world in which actually we're assuming that Adam
Brody's character is the one that yelled she's
here but really it was Alex Oh you mean like it's
a Twist on that that's what we saw and they wanted
us to see I mean but I'll make it right Mr leel
[Music] interesting take on Rich Society secret
society all that stuff you mean interesting
take on Army Hammer family right there you
go well we'll see if they eat her probably
watch this movie and goes this is all very
true oh my goodness Alex you better walk in right
now oh he's coming prediction does she live or die
I think she lives I think he's going to wipe
most of them out okay who do you think lives
not the dad I think her and Alex are going
to live why can't he do it oh he's sick oh
is it poison oh what what maybe poon Adam Brody
poison them Adam did wow yeah cuz he's not sick
is that his Redemption he said they all deserve
to die it's a good Redemption for him I knew it
well I didn't know exactly it but I mean we were
calling like earlier on like there it's got to
be a Redemption for him I you'd help me I didn't
all I knew is at some point somebody had to burn
it all down thought be me Daniel oh your husband
you really don't care if I die you don't have to
do
o thank you that really sucks yeah but
smart girl she was she was like you're
dead so I'm gone she said thank
you and I'm going to do it right
here oh burning it all down this place
going down the thing is though if she
lives does Alex die I know she doesn't
think it's real but no is she going to
think is he going to think that it was her
who did it I need you that his wife did
it you got to get up though dude it's like some
satisfying dialogue I'm not going to let you hurt
my family oh he's going to have to literally
pick between the two of them like he claimed
he would yeah that was foreshadowing up yeah
oh she she going to hit her with the Box she
going to pull another card I don't know
no she just going to hit her with the Box
yeah you don't deserve a f family you're
right no she doesn't deserve this family oh
no oh no he walks in
Grace dude come on you know what they've been
trying to do to her all night really still his
mama's boy and he saw what happened to his brother
oh no no don't H she's in here what what Mom said
she knew I think he's the one who did it as a kid
oh you think that was really more of a Twist I
do sh for us sham for us I still
feel like she's going to survive I
just don't know what's going to happen
right now I don't know I I I'm 5050
I'm ooh you turn oh she has a knife what
happens when the sun comes up yeah like
is it Supernatural like they're saying or do
they all start dropping [Music] dead it is lost
and they don't die yeah forgive us nothing
happens you played a game for no reason now
oh my God uhuh should we play another game
maybe up for Checkers chess I knew it it's
all [__] oh know Grace yeah F you I know it
is too late but I will not fail you again the
rules are the rules you can't do anything
whoa who did it oh no she burst because of
the morning they are all going to die oh he's
killing them oh okay so it okay so it is real I
guess I think you were right yeah I
want to go home are the little boys
too yep I think that answers that
I played by the rules and I'm in
control later I really didn't think
the supernatural element was going to
be inserted sweetie Grace I'm really
scared don't touch me no okay I want
toor so she still gets the money right
I hope she gets everything but the house
is burnt down I don't think she really cares right
now can you explain that to the cops um they
just naturally combusted into
nothingness whoa that was a
crazy all right you need to go to the hospital
right now for your hand oh Legend but it's like
an epically way to do like she's a hero now with
that the rendition of how they're doing it her
dress is black look at all the white still oh
what a cool shot I love her ma'am are you okay
you hear me I've got someone on the south lawn we
need paramedics over here I mean she's going to
need therapy the rest of her life but she's fine
she's probably so proud of herself Jesus Christ
what happened to you in-laws it was funny there
was a lot of a lot of jokes a lot of good humor
damn that was very good yeah no the setup and the
World building for this uh the whole idea of this
was just really well done the uh the suspense
too it just I loved it um it's a good lesson here
for all of us if any of us ever meet a very rich
person who's got a very wealthy family the first
thing you got to ask them on the date is do you
guys have any type of weird games you play after
yeah rituals that if we get married like cuz I saw
this film ready or not and I just want to know is
this something I'm going to have to do so cuzz
it is I'm so in I'm with you also I just can't
believe how good that movie was yeah no I loved
it that was like just the greatest I mean imagine
coming up with that premise did the directors also
write this I'm curious I'm not sure imagine coming
up with that premise and just being like yeah okay
let's run with it I mean that's just so smart so
different like that classic it's almost like like
an Agatha Christy novel on crack where it's just
like we're we're stuck in one location I love
movies like that but the way that we introduce it
the entire First Act or I guess until the inciting
incident of her uh pulling the card was like what
are they actually going to do here and then even
with uh Daniel's character ending up being the
one that is the good guy whatever you want to call
him and Alex character flipping and his mom being
like I know at the end of the day you're going to
choose your family and then him doing that I just
think it was such smart storytelling really solid
premise really solid storytelling yeah and it made
sense too because from Daniel's perspective like
just he felt so guilty with what happened with
Elaine's husband at the beginning and then just
living with that guilt for years and how I mean
what that does to a child and then growing up with
that and then from Alex's perspective like you
know again like that's a very difficult decision
then Daniel was that was his brother and/ best
friend and then seeing his mother like and again
he didn't see what happened to uh to Daniel so he
figured that it was his wife that had done that
and didn't realize that it was Daniel's wife so
and again to his wife's uh defense she was she
was in self-defense the whole film even if she
had K even if she had killed Daniel like again she
was just defending her herself so that would have
been Justified but I think it was more about the
mom yeah the that speech that she gave him like
yeah no for sure but yeah again either way just
like you side with her just because again she's
defending herself so it's Justified either way
but that was a good again that was really good
writing um but I just thought this film just did
such a great job just balancing so many different
things from the humor to the suspense and the
tension and the jump scares there's so many
different elements that I just really appreciate
it and just the the again the World building and
the setups and everything just so many different
things and the psychological aspects of this film
there was just so many different and also too
I was just on my toes all F like I have there
was only like I feel like there's only one thing I
was able to predict like with Georgie and the farm
and all that but I like I love when I'm I don't
see things coming in films I hate when I'm able
to see things coming so I think that's you know
credit to the writers for you know me not being
able to you know see things that were foreshadowed
or coming oh I guess too like Daniel's Redemption
Arc too but I mean that's that's pretty standard
I mean you could I mean I think we could both
see that was coming but it was just I was happy
that he got one because I felt no child should
have to go through that that was that's terrible
they really go down every path I feel like they
they fleshed out every possible twist turn idea
and then they picked the best on for it but you
mentioned the psychological elements and you
know the psychologists talk about between the
ages of one and seven really making shaping who
you are as a person and that you can't really um
you can of course change and grow and overcome
different things but who you are a lot of it is
really defined in those years and we see that what
she had to deal with and we can only imagine right
she says she has no family she's in the foster
care system like how that shaped her versus how
Daniel and Alex were shaped and even though Alex
did decide to get out at some point who he is is
kind of who he is um and it even though he was
able to make that decision to leave it's Daniel
who's the one who was able to finally and when
when she says I knew you'd help me and he said
I didn't I really feel like it was 50/50 it wasn't
like he was always going to help her it really was
like in that moment after already seeing his
sister and her daugh and her son Georgie and
being like all of us deserve to die I feel like
he really had like a almost come to Jesus moment
where he's like this girl didn't do anything she's
too good for our family he says that from the jump
right he did really like her he hates his effing
wife cuz she's a socio and I think he just decided
like uh this is it for me like and and I think
he knew it would kill him one way or the other
I think he really believed that by helping her he
was going to die regardless of whether it was by
the hand of his wife or by the sunshine in the
morning yeah I know I legit I I really did feel
bad for Daniel and I guess to some effect I also
felt bad for uh Elaine I believe her name was as
well just from what happened to uh her husband
at the very beginning and also too I I really
didn't actually like with the way it was end um
I didn't expect the actual Supernatural element I
didn't think they were actually going to go there
but they had told us validity for it throughout
right they had shown us or said like this is what
happened to this cousin this is what happened to
this Aunt they didn't play they didn't do this but
we didn't know if everybody would die because we
hadn't seen that yeah but I mean I just thought
that was just like lines I didn't actually think
that's what I I just thought he was just saying it
just so people would fall in line and just follow
the rules of the game just like Scare Tactics
so you you know follow so that they would do it
but with the game right you put the card in and
something comes out yeah so there's hideand-seek
and I believe no I'm just saying that's a super
natural element and of itself right like that
was the one that I felt like was the first time
that they were queuing us into the fact that this
is not just um your world yeah yeah yeah exactly
because I don't think that they were saying like
oh a different card pops out I think you put the
card in and he decides yes what it is that comes
out Lael right I believe yeah yeah he decides yeah
exactly who they made the deal with but yeah know
and what did you think of the uh how violent the
film was I think they did a really good job with
that I feel like it was the perfect level of
violence like it wasn't gratuitous violence for
the sake of being that I think when you're dealing
with something like this the premise it has to be
pretty violent but it wasn't like super violent
um and then like here's all the boobies you know
just like for funsies I think that the the premise
is a bunch of rich people are trying to kill this
foster child who their kid is with and they know
she has no family they know she has nobody who's
looking for her they know that she whatever it is
and they they end up of course there's going to
be huge amount of violence for that so I felt that
it made a lot of sense how about you yeah um sorry
just it says right there there's not sufficient
dis space to continue should I ask Craig about
that really Qui oh um I don't know I just ask
yeah Greg when did it pop up I just noticed it
we're in the review portion but I just noticed
there's not sufficient dis space to continue
recording I don't know when
that popped up I didn't notice
it okay so we're good to keep
going
no
worries yeah the joy your
Pepsi yeah this is for the sink thank you thank
you yeah no I thought um well the first scene
where Elaine's husband was just shot with the
arrows there wasn't too much violence there so
it didn't really how is that not too much violence
well I mean it is violent I just mean in terms of
graphic violence yeah Gore there you go exactly
so I don't usually I mean I'm not the most it's
it's it's hard for me to watch violence but
I mean it makes for good reactions I'll give
you that or at least youall be the judge if
you think it makes for good reactions I don't
usually handle well like for instance films
like the saw films I haven't really watched
those I've maybe seen like 20 seconds I usually
don't handle Gore well but I thought this film
like I don't know I actually enjoyed it like I
I thought it was fun to watch uh just with the
dark humor in this film I just thought it like
it it was a nice staple with everything else I
just thought it all balanced well um I I thought
it was so funny though the I for I think it was
Emily or whatever the the daughter like was the
cokehead and she couldn't like handle the gun
or anything she was accidentally shooting Maids
like why doesn't this ever work for me whatever
why is this always happen to me yeah like and
then they were reassuring you it's okay honey
don't worry about it like there's always there are
family members like that so it's like that is a
very relatable trait and and in a Sea of Monsters
that we're watching it's like there was something
relatable there I just found that like to be
obviously not when I say the word Charming I
don't mean like in the situ I just mean Charming
in the sense of like just it's a family related
matter that I think that's something we can all
relate to but not the actual and also just the
self-centeredness of some family members like
why is it always happening to me while you've
just murdered multiple different people I do think
they did a really good job with the Ensemble of
this everybody getting like I feel like I had a
grip on all of the characters um using the word
favorite but not meaning like the best human but
did you have a favorite Ensemble member that's
a great I really love them all um the actress who
played aane she just did a good job of just really
feeling like she was I mean she always felt like
she wanted that kill but she also felt like she
had so much like Ju Just from what happened to her
uh husband at the very beginning you could tell
like just how haunted she was and you know she was
just just uh just feeling so pissed off about what
had happened and like again just the word I would
use haunted and just i' say like her eyes were
just telling a story for me and I would say like
she stood out to me but I loved um what's waving
yeah she was phenomenal I just loved watching her
transformation um I think you said it best though
just because of everything she had to deal with in
the foster care system it just it it was totally
understandable why her character was able to
transform into such a badass because she's already
had such a difficult life um obviously I don't
know if anything can prepare you for this type
of situation but but they put that in quick for us
to understand just by giving us a few lines it's
like you know um because I have a a lot of close
people in my life who went through the Foster and
you find out very quickly so some are better than
other some um families housing that were better
than others so who knows maybe she didn't have but
based on her being like I have no family it sounds
like she's not like in touch with any of the the
families that she was raised with so very quickly
you have a picture of her childhood that like I
think that they just did such a great job putting
into the script because we can all imagine right
why she picked this guy why like what a fantasy
she thinks she's walking into this home that's
beautiful this like she's like I'm so excited to
join this dysfunctional family cuz just cuz it's
a family so you can imagine what that looks like
for her and how much she wants this yeah and then
just to like be gutted by that but yeah no Elaine
like again the animosity that that actress just
again all fantastic I love them all that that they
all just nailed that creepy Vibe and um also
too at the same point that family Dynamic cuz
even though they were doing something disturbing
and disgusting I tood their motivations and what
they were doing from the supernatural element of
the game that they were playing so like from that
perspective and also to from the actors as well
like at the end of the day they're just actors
and they don't really know each other too well
and they've only got you know the um they're
they're just doing um you know they only have
so much time to rehearse and do all that but I
really felt that they had a history with each
other and that you know that and such but um
they did such a great job uh in terms of that but
did you have a fa favorite family member I think
that probably it was Adam Brody just because he
had the biggest character Arc um and I also just
everything that he said and did at first when
she's just sitting there looking in the mirror
talking to herself right before the wedding and
we don't know what the premise of the movie is we
don't know what's happening we did see of course
the opening moments but we don't know what's going
to happen with her um and she's just saying you
know and a brother-in-law who gets drunk and hits
on me I have such a clear image of this guy just
being the biggest douche in the family right like
and then as we as we start to understand what's
actually happening here and he feels guilty about
the kind of brother he's been his he thinks his
wife is a nightmare and he picked the wrong one
like uh you know all of the things he's not a
saint and and I don't feel bad for him because
he still made all these choices however for him
to have that Redemption moment he stands in front
of her it was just so great um and then on the
other end of that my probably the other person
that I really was like wow was Andy McDow because
she had the opposite with her character Arc right
like when we meet her for the first conversation
she's like stand tall and say [__] him you know
you got this babe and she's like rooting for
her and had she pulled a different card the
Checker's card I'm sure that her and Andy could
have been great friends you know and it was then
to see her by the end really try to be the last
one to nail her yeah yeah and then when she looks
and says [__] you you know she stood tall and I
would state from character perspective I totally
agree with you that Adam Brody was my favorite of
the family in terms of just act actor I would say
Elaine I just like I said she just sold me with
they all were they were all yeah yeah again they
were they were all fantastic I love them all uh
my final question for you did you have a favorite
Gore moment because for me personally it was when
she stuck her shot hand into that nail that was
that's the one that really has jump right yeah
that was the most gory despicably disgusting
moment for me I think that was a really good one
I also liked the moment not liked but the moment
in the fence I was about to say going through
the fence was especially because what happens
after that is that like these are the moments that
happen in our actual lives not this movie you're
driving by somebody and you have to make that
Split Second decision like what do you do and
we have lost Humanity in a lot of ways because
because also we're each individually scared now
that driver shouted [__] you get out of the road
so obviously that wasn't the case there but like I
think about this all the time every time I drive
by somebody that is hitchhiking or somebody who
might need help and then you hear about stories
about people who go to help somebody and they get
killed right so it's like you do you put your
own life first in those moments do you put uh
strangers life first you know so I think that that
Gore moment then leading up to to no Prevail I was
like wow that was very very well done yeah for
sure I mean it adds to the groundedness of the
film I would say too like if you ever find
yourself in that situation you know you have
to assess um it's understandable to drive away
but also too don't shout yeah yeah no no totally
totally um I mean there's also too you could maybe
even say like hey do you want me to call someone
for you and then you know again it's it's all
about assess a risk and assessment she clearly is
like a small but yeah you never know how Mighty
somebody is you never exactly you never know
someone could be hiding and but you just you never
known today's day and age I mean any uh nitpicks
from you that's a great question um you know right
now fresh uh nothing right now that stood out to
me that bothered me too much um but I just like
I said I just love the balance between uh the the
suspense the tension the music by Brian Tyler I
thought he just did a great job I love the dark
humor uh the gore I just the ensemble cast um
as you mentioned Adam Brody's character uh the
way you got that Redemption Arc and then the twist
with Alex's character and then how badass she was
I just there was so many elements of this film I
really appreciated and again just the premise of
this just really brilliantly and I just loved it
so no nitpicks nothing right now stands out I'm
sure when I if I think about a little bit more I
mean how about you I think that the there was um
the moment in the car right where she's talking
to that guy okay that's a good one actually where
I was just kind of like I I understand the car
service turning off I but like he was she was like
somebody's trying to kill me can you call the cops
and he was like uh can you not use profanity I was
like that's just like a normal person working
a desk job if anybody calls about that kind of
thing like and then you would call the cops now
the cops did come at the end so maybe that was
just the timeline wise and and I'm not saying that
the cops have the quickest arrival time so maybe
he did call but I did feel like that felt a little
forced dialogue wise like just slightly forced for
the convenience of what was happening I thought
you were going to say that was kind of dumb of
her to try and call someone someone just like
drive away get help instead of actually trying
to make that call I thought you were going to
go there and I was going to say like when you're
in the frame of mind of survival mode you're not
really thinking in logical sense in logical terms
so obviously I've never been there but I can only
imagine how much your heart is racing and you're
again I think it's totally reasonable that she
would be frantic and click to call like you know
you look for a phone call my whatever it is but
I just think the guy on the other line was like
yeah you know for the all of the um that who they
refer to as the help were all on their team but
this guy isn't directly working with them yeah and
I do remember there was one line of dialogue I I
don't think you cared for it was when she started
doing the Coke or something there was a line that
she said and you were like you you thought it was
funny but you're like it was kind of stupid too
there was a couple lines where that I was like
that was funny but a little Force but it did fit
the tone of this like this like obscure world so
I was totally okay with that but most of it was
actually felt very grounded dialogue wise so then
when some of those moments stood out and then it's
just a pet peeve of mine too in movies where um
this is going to sound so ridiculous but like if
you're going to have a a drug be used in a movie
you need to know how that drug is used and it was
just funny to see her like cup it's just like I
don't know watch some kind of like alapon dock
right something um anyway all right well ready or
not ready or not here we go here we go that was
that was good though I really enjoyed it yeah that
was I mean I would say that that was as close to
a perfect movie as I've ever as I've ever seen
like it just really did it for me I would give
that a 9.5 out of 10 I'd probably go the same
ride and I also say too I forgot to mention the
tone of it I just felt so Eerie the whole time
and from jump yeah for sure I'm with you uh well
thank you guys I don't think there was a patron
that he just told us to sh out did I make that up
I don't just talk like this and they cannot even
know that are are moving do you know I could you
in triloquist in a different life I was going to
say are you triloquist I think I'm pretty good at
it actually if you ask me um thank you guys ready
or not here we leave you can't hide you're gonna
find me and make you want me uh that's pretty much
it you guys rock and thank you for being here with
us don't forget like comment subscribe all that
good stuff and we'll see you next time see you
guys